how much of a breakthrough do you think
it is
i do believe this is an important
scientific breakthrough
the results are extremely encouraging i
feel very optimistic about this
potential vaccine it did all the things
that we expected of it
and so far it seems safe and well
tolerated
so i think we can move forward into
phase three studies
with some degree of confidence um andrew
pollard saying it's a critical
milestone but then he says there's still
lots to do
you agree with that dude
yeah there is a lot to do um first of
all
we have to make sure that this vaccine
can
actually protect people from getting
viral infection and the study that we
published today
hasn't shown that yet it's just simply
shown that we do generate an
immune response so that's a big step
forward
those those trials those phase three
trials are currently being conducted
in brazil in south africa and in the
united kingdom
and we should get the results of those
studies later this year and that's going
to be the next
big test yeah and so those um
patients uh involved in the trial are
sort of waiting to get it are they is
that is that the situation
well you have to do these studies now in
areas where there's a lot of virus where
there's a lot of community transmission
so you
you take a large number of people and
you
give half of them the vaccine and half
of them are control
and then you wait and see what happens
and what you're hoping for is that a
significant number of people who are
given the oxford vaccine will not get
infection
and if we get that result and we also
know that the vaccine is safe
and well tolerated then we're in a good
position to start producing
okay and um already the race is on to
secure access
to these vaccines that have not yet been
produced the government here has signed
deals for over 100 million doses the
american government
400 million doses is this the
is this the right way to do it it does
seem that every country's
you know looking after itself here
well mark this is absolutely the wrong
way to do it if i'm
if i might say this is now going to be a
struggle
um between the richest and most powerful
countries to
basically buy up whatever vaccine is
there that is not the right way to do it
because countries that are poorer that
don't have the money or the muscle
are not going to get access what we need
is to make sure that the vaccine goes to
those who need the vaccine
most of all and we know that that people
who are older
people who are living with chronic
illness health workers on the front line
of the disease
people who are from black and minority
ethnic communities
we know who's at risk they should get
the vaccine first
and then everybody else so i hope that
countries can come together
to figure out a way of fairly
distributing the vaccine otherwise it
really
is just going to be a race to the bottom
well i mean that may not happen what
happened to the
distribution protocols of of gavi you
know the
the vaccine alliance who said exactly
that that it should go first to those
health workers first i think it was and
then those who need it most
well these are all good intentions but
when
reality hits i'm afraid governments
ignore those good intentions and just go
in and try
and buy up the vaccine they can't
remember president trump
tried to buy a vaccine company in
germany the entire company
so we have to constrain government's
enthusiasm
uh here and figure out a global
framework
of convention so to speak whereby we
have
fair access to the vaccine and i hope
that wise heads can prevail
so that governments can come together
even in this country
not everybody should get the vaccine at
the same time only those who are most
at risk but it does need leadership and
perhaps we don't have so much of that
global leadership right now
and what do you make of the i think the
uk survey
that said 14 would not have a vaccine 13
would think about not having it so
you know 27 could refuse to have
a vaccine what do you make of that i
think in the us
it was 50 percent uh uh committing to
taking the vaccine that that few exactly
exactly only half of people in the us
when polled recently would would be
willing to take the vaccine
well this is uh this is my biggest
concern that
the the anti-vaccination movement is
mobilizing again
and could cause significant
harm to public confidence in taking the
vaccine
so it's very important that we're as
transparent as possible
and we explain the science and we
explain
the benefits as well as any potential
harms of a vaccine
and that's why this information we've
published today is fully in the public
domain any member of the public can
access it for free
and i would encourage every person who's
interested to go
and read this paper it is technical but
that
it is understandable too and you can see
the way in which the study has been done
and i do believe
having reviewed this paper and published
it this afternoon
that we should have every confidence in
the oxford researchers
for the incredibly careful way they've
done this research and the
excellent way they have reported it to
be as transparent as possible
but we need to begin now mark to build
public confidence
in the vaccine program that will come
to fruition over the next 12 months yeah
so you know what's coming i mean it's
the obvious question
did the lancet contribute to this crisis
in confidence
uh in vaccines with the publication of
that paper under you
suggesting a link between the mmr
vaccine and autism
well that story is 20 years old now over
20 years old
and there's no doubt that that paper did
do harm to the confidence that the
public had in
mmr and the campaign that andrew
wakefield
waged against the vaccine but we're in a
different era now
public confidence has been restored in
vaccines and i think that the covert 19
epidemic that we're living in has really
made people
realize how important it is to escape
this situation that we're now in and the
only way that we're going to escape this
situation
safely is with a safe and effective
vaccine
and that's the step forward we're on to
today
and i know you you've retracted this
article after i think it was 12 years
you regret that now do you
i don't regret retracting the article
running it in the first place obviously
oh yes i mean if we knew if we knew
what we knew uh if we knew then what we
know now
about andrew wakefield and that work
then
we certainly wouldn't have published
that that
so-called research and to what extent do
you think
your publication of that has damaged
destroyed for some people confidence in
vaccines
how what responsibility do you think you
hold for that
i think that we certainly
the paper when it was first published
and andrew wakefield's campaign against
the mmr vaccine
contributed to a decline in public
confidence there's no question of that
but that confidence has been built
up again in vaccines and i do not
believe there has been any lasting
damage to public confidence in vaccines
when you look at the rates of vaccine
uptake in the uk
they're very high and of course they can
always be higher
but i think we're going into a phase
with this vaccine
if we can establish its effectiveness
and its safety i believe the public will
be very willing
to be recipients of this vaccine because
it's the only way to get us out
of the situation we're currently in but
is is confidence really being rebuilt
when you've got this
london school for hygiene tropical
medicine saying a
survey saying around 25
one in four may not take uh have this
vaccine in the u.s
as i was just saying half the population
are refusing to commit to taking the
vaccine how do you
how do you say that that the confidence
is being rebuilt it doesn't look like it
does it
well different countries have different
reasons for why they
are hesitant about vaccines so in the
united states
there is certainly a very strong
what's called vaccine hesitancy movement
or anti-vaccination movement
and that's partly because uh you've got
a very populist government that
people are anti-science anti-elites not
trusting
in the government and all of those
different influences
are creating a lack of confidence in
a vaccine but it's symptomatic of a
broader lack of trust
in government and in experts and elites
in this country we're in a very
different situation we don't have that
degree of mistrust or distrust
of government and of scientific experts
we're
we're in a very strong position here
where there's very high public trust
in the scientific community and very
high public trust
in doctors and what we do need to do now
is to prepare
for a vaccine and that means building
public confidence and expectations in
the science
and the practice of this vaccine
and where it's coming from so i believe
we do have high levels of confidence in
the uk
right and look you've been very critical
of the government response to covert
over the months
slow complacent flat-footed glaringly
unprepared
do you still feel that way and is it
entirely fair
when this was a completely new disease
hitting the world
very suddenly
well mark we published five papers in
the last week of january
and if you go back and read those five
papers the entire story of the last six
months is set out
there human to human transmission a new
virus tipping people into intensive care
with a very high mortality rate
the urgent need for ppe test trace and
isolate
every debate we've had in the last six
months was set out in those five papers
but those five papers were ignored and
we wasted six weeks through february and
early march when we should have built
been building up our public health
protection
systems so that we could have avoided
the
terrible toll immortality that we have
seen
so we did know enough and we did know
enough
early on to prevent the tragedies and
disaster
that we are currently living through you
said the sage scientists were
the public relations wing of the
government isn't that
harsh on scientists who l you know just
after all are doing their best
oh i completely agree we've got
excellent scientists
in the uk and they've all done their
very best
but the system broke down the system
failed
we've got think about it we have a chief
medical officer
we have a chief scientific advisor with
their offices we have a committee called
nerve tag a committee called
sage a committee called spy b a
committee called spy m
we've got this byzantine complex system
of science advice
where lots of different pieces of
goodbyes are all being thrown
into government but there's very little
coordination
no command and control nobody takes
final responsibility
and yet we knew at the end of january
that
this virus was on its way one of those
papers said
very clearly that the risk of a global
pandemic
was very real and the world health
organization declared a public health
emergency of international concern
on january the 30th the biggest red flag
that they can wave
and we ignored it both the scientists
and government did too little
too late to pay attention to those i
don't think
i don't think they ignored it i think
that's a little unfair but we've run out
of time but just just finally
uh richard so the you know the man who
published the the paper the wakefield
paper you would encourage people now
to have this vaccine you would tell
people to have this vaccine no question
about that
no this vaccine isn't ready for human
use yet
no no no i mean should we have one
should we have one that is successfully
and safely produced and
would be safe for the widespread
population you would encourage them to
have that vaccine
i would absolutely be confident if this
vaccine passes safety and efficacy tests
in phase 3 trials
i'd be absolutely confident that we
would have a vaccine for widespread
human use and it should be produced
and deployed as rapidly as possible if
we get to that stage